de l'Ukraine voilà donc c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment un virage important et
c'est la fin c'est la fin de ce semblant
de normalité et puis c'est aussi un
message qui semble assez clair de la
part du président russe Vladimir Poutine
nous pouvons frapper partout et tout le
temps et nous pouvons en particulier
frapper au cœur des grandes villes du
crâne et c'est ça l'objectif en fait de
Poutine c'est de traumatiser la
population en tout cas quand les camps
des civils quand des quartiers
résidentiels dans ces grandes villes
sont touchées il y a un manquablement
une forme de une forme de terreur qui
est instaurée une forme de peur
d'angoisse qui qui fait son retour au
sein de la population on se rappelle là
encore du début du conflit du début de
l'invasion russe durant les premières
semaines les deux premiers mois en
particulier du conflit on se rappelle de
ces sirènes qui retentissaient en
permanence dans les grandes villes on se
rappelle de la population qui se cachait
dans ses abris souterrains presque
toutes les nuits là encore il y avait eu
un revirement assez important
dans les mois qui ont dans les mois qui
ont suivi je me rappelle d'un autre d'un
autre voyage en Ukraine durant lequel
j'avais couvert le conflit au mois de
juin et et là j'étais notamment passé à
Kiev et une vie quotidienne avait repris
son cours le métro à verrou vert les
terrasse était bondé les les rues
étaient de nouveau bondées et là on peut
craindre que de nouveau y est un climat
de peur effectivement qui s'instaure et
que de nouveau peut-être les rues
commencent à se vider il faut toutefois
signaler qu'il y a un changement
important depuis le début du conflit
c'est
ce sont les victoires que remporte
l'armée ukrainienne et qui galvanise
d'une certaine manière la population il
y a d'ailleurs de nombreux habitants qui
avaient quitté l'Ukraine qui aujourd'hui
reviennent qui reviennent d'ailleurs
depuis déjà plusieurs mois donc il y a
quand même un changement d'état d'esprit
au sein de la population donc voilà il
faut pas non plus s'attendre un
mouvement de panique encore une fois
l'état d'esprit des Ukrainiens a
beaucoup changé ces derniers mois vous
le disiez l'armée ukrainienne la
multiplier les les victoires sur le
terrain que ça soit dans le don basse à
Kerson là c'est une manière pour Poutine
de dire voilà le jeu la guerre n'est pas
terminée il essaye de reprendre la main
ce qui est sûr c'est que en tout cas
Poutine veut montrer qui qui reprend la
main il faudra faire plus pour remporter
cette guerre que frapper que frapper les
centres-villes des grandes
agglomérations ukrainiennes cette guerre
elle se joue sur les lignes de front
autour de airsson autour de rakif dans
le bon basse mais en tout cas à quelques
heures de ce Conseil de sécurité que que
le président russe réunit tout à l'heure
oui il veut montrer qu'il reprend la
main il y a ses frappes qu'on vient
d'évoquer il y a les déclarations du
président Belarus le catchenko qui dit
qu'il va déployer ses troubles sur le
territoire ukrainien il y a aussi des
déclarations belliqueuses du dirigeant
tchétchène Ramzan Kadirov donc tous ces
éléments rassemblés clairement
témoignent du fait que le président
Poutine veut reprendre la main ou en
tout cas montrer qu'il reprend la main
ne serait-ce que ne serait-ce que dans
dans les était dans les déclarations et
de ces derniers jours merci beaucoup
John retournons de la guerre dans ces
zones qui étaient depuis quelques
semaines maintenant épargnés notamment
Kiev à l'inverse de sloviande ce